very excited to have sardia Khan on my
podcast not only is she stunning she's a
psychologist she actually gives people
advice on relationships and Trauma Saudi
is now based here in Dubai and offers
online coaching online okay so she's
some kind of like I guess dating coach
in Dubai in Dubai yeah okay basically
she puts a price tag on the women and
the men by this was her job
is it really that no no she just brings
the toilet paper for the porta potties
I'm being stupid yeah because I've I've
seen many cases or I've heard oh you
know so-and-so's partner cheats and
stuff like that but it's like it's for
me in in some cases it it's kind of like
an open marriage no or is it I always
say that high value men are more likely
to be cheated on back they just don't
realize it really absolutely I always
say rich men are the most likely to be
cheated on especially in defy why
because the women they choose a hundred
percent
hahaha
a hundred percent we get spicy today a
hundred percent
hey they don't realize it they just
don't realize it I'm I'm gonna say two
things
a lot of a lot of the rich men like
publicly rich men that I know
can't keep a relationship or they can't
keep a loyal chick
just saying that's it that's right all
this talk about high value man get
respect not from they women for whatever
reason listen a lot of them don't seem
to get yes they can move on to the next
girl really easy and replace her
whatever girls they get with they can
also replace those dudes generally
speaking oh my Dave my guy that's why
you'll see the same you'll see the same
girl with 10 different Rich guys because
they all cycle through the same women
because the same women got the same
amount of options it's kind of a crazy
thing to think about but if you don't
notice it a lot of these Instagram
thoughties who have terrible reputation
begin with multiple of these dudes they
just be running through the game bit
working in the bar as the street in the
in the club industry in the hotel
industry the food and beverage teach you
so much about that it's what you see at
some point you're like you see the same
people
the same Cycles you know you see them
with different people and stuff like
that if you're if you're in a town if
you're in a city that a lot of uh stars
goes through
you start to realize is the same people
around them dying girl
so yeah the women are treated like
Ethiopian food everyone is from the same
place with the hands
well the women when you're a broke man
you're limited in terms of the women you
can access you can only access the
limited range of women so you're only
going to access a simple kind of woman
because you're a simple man that simple
woman doesn't have many options so
you're both optionless and you're both
good to go you've got a connection
you're good to go now if you are a high
value man let's take it let's say for
example you're a George Clooney you can
access whoever you want in the world no
whoever you want so you could choose a
Kim if you're Kanye you can choose a Kim
do you think Kanye is the only rich man
she knows no do you think Kanye is the
best she can get she can get many of you
so what happens is as a man becomes more
successful his criteria and selection of
women becomes more provocative
promiscuous It's usually the dream girl
that
yeah I got I got a girl in that place I
got holes in that area code no he don't
have holes in that area code
that hoe has a lot of dude that comes
through the area code
yo I'm in your town what's up you think
you're the only you
you
think you're the only one
yo I mean you're
dream girl knows 10 of you but if you
choose that you know simple girl that
works in Starbucks of course she's going
to be loyal to you but what high value
man chooses that he chooses the sexiest
girl on screen
so he's always I always say to men who
are high value Rich especially in Dubai
before I've even met that girl I'm like
she's cheating on you why because she
likes you for your lifestyle and she
knows plenty of men with your lifestyle
you're just covering her current bills
I feel bad for men now like
[Music]
I feel like don't feel bad for them
because they choose this life they could
easily choose a simple nice woman but
they choose this life yeah but still
it's like you know they work they work
hard they work hard they you know go to
the gym they try and be like they've
become masculine they cover the bills
they're just trying to find it it's a
really poor deal for them because it's a
really poor deal because what happens is
they're the ones doing everything yeah
yeah both are cheating but she's doing
it on your watch and she's doing it with
your credit card so he's getting a way
worse deal way worse deal but I always
say it's your selection process who
tells you to date these kind of women
that you know you know had a billionaire
in the past and had all this work done
you think she got that for free it's
you'll send that you have to look at
your selection process you feel bad for
them I don't feel bad for them like I
don't oh don't look at the high value
man in this penthouse for this million
dollars I'm being so bad bro
he was with that Super Mario Bros don't
you feel bad for him I don't know you he
he got 100 [__] in his DMS don't you
feel bad for him with all them options
don't you look at his little poor little
boo-boo he's hurting in his Penthouse
you look with his yard don't you feel
bad for the high value on my own you
look like Eddie Murphy trying to
impersonate bill I don't feel bad I
don't feel bad at all oh my God I don't
feel bad don't you feel bad for these
multi-millionaires with their children I
don't give up I don't feel bad I don't
feel bad for the girls I don't feel bad
for the guys to me it's just
y'all chose that life yeah not one of
the whole options thing expected loyalty
it's a choice that's why I feel bad for
nobody everybody got to choose their
life they do they think and it is what
it is it says as you get more successful
you choose more promiscuous what do you
expect
yeah they always do you don't see
footballers flying out uh a librarian
you know they you know they're not gonna
go I would I'm not going live you a
librarian then you kind of hey you can
holler at your boy okay I'm gonna tell
you this uh if you're a librarian and
you got a list and when you talk you
sound like you're wet
yep
we are going to enjoy it together fly
out a teacher on a Lads out they're
flying out the only fans girl and it's
only a matter of time before you get
lost in the sauce and you make that only
fans go your girlfriend yo what she said
is so fixed if you guys actually pay
attention a lot of these red pill
goobers end up getting wiping up girls
who either did some kind of X work in
the past or had only fans before or
whatever it is another reformed which
Hey listen you should be with whoever
you want but I find it so funny that
they denigrate these women and the one
and they turn into Captain Save A holes
themselves end up on wifey whoever turn
up as a girlfriend it happens so often
y'all ever notice that they be sourcing
their women from Sugar Baby sites and
stuff like that it's just funny to me
because they they [__] talking these
women but they go on the very mediums
where you meet these women so it's just
there is an incongruence between the
values they Expose and how they try to
find their women what do you think about
the whole idea the wrist guys getting
cheated on the most all right three it
happens I I agree not the most but I
agree that it happens it's very it's
very actually no let me take that back
I think it is the most
yeah it is the most uh the only thing I
disagree with is
well well not gonna disagree that I
don't feel the same way is I don't feel
bad for nobody
for nobody I'm not um
oh important thing like he steps out
while you live in a big that's what you
wanted that's what you aim for that's
what you want and that's fine you know I
mean there's a there's pros and cons in
both I don't feel bad I don't feel good
I'm just like it is what it is it comes
with pros and cons to live that kind of
Life uh on the side of the man on the
side of the woman it's not I'm not
trashing nobody I don't care I'll say
this
there are studies out there that show
that the higher amount of Partners you
have the more likely you are to engage
with infidelity now it doesn't mean that
because you had a lot you're going to do
that what it does show however is
there's an access that leads to
Temptation that leads to end result and
if you think about high value men's and
the kind of women to get with most of
them are people who have been
promiscuous because they have the most
amount of opportunities thus the most
smart Temptation it doesn't mean that a
really hot girl is going to do it it
just means she's far more likely to
because she has far more options right
if you live in a place with more crime
and more guns and more this you're
probably going to see more shootings
that's just kind of how these things
work so just understand when you think
about infidelity and all this markers
people who live in that kind of higher
Stratosphere are the most likely to be
cheated on and the most likely to engage
in infidelity because it's all around
them it's a lot easier to be loyal when
there's not a bunch of women who are
attractive saying they want to suck you
off in your DMs or go out trips with you
and they got every of the finest bikini
pictures possible known to man
that's a reality of the lifestyle so
anybody who comes to me says who gets
cheat on the most it's going to be rich
people it's going to people who are
really well off
100 of the time it's gonna be them
doesn't mean it doesn't happen to others
fears absolutely does okay and it's
probably more insulting to be cheated on
by a broke man but at the end of the day
you still got cheated on so it is what
it is
that's how I think about it and she
right she must I don't think she was
right about everything he said but she's
definitely right about that person she's
not lying she's not lying there's whole
like making money and all this stuff or
being famous and it comes with its
downsides I guarantee you if you look at
the marriage rate or the successful
relationship like all this thing rates
for people who make like an exponential
amount of money or people who are really
well known you're gonna see they are far
far more likely to fail and that's not
even rocket science or anything
groundbreaking that's just reality so
all this time we spend glorifying that
high value life just know
they got their own problems and I don't
know if a lot of you are built for those
problems More Money More Problems
he was coming back I don't think it's
more problems just definitely different
problems true
true
yeah I'd be trying to navigate both
sides pretty efficiently what kind of I
live a good life but I make enough money
to be part of the other life but I don't
spend it that way therefore I don't
attract the attention of the problems
that the other life gives you get what
I'm trying to say
like if I'm dating somebody and you met
them you would never think that they're
part of that kind of crazy weird high
value life because they don't move like
that because that's the values I search
for so I try to do but a lot of that
because I know who all of a sudden they
make money all of a sudden they girls
they went from Human to like
80 plastic right there's a shift that
happens where the percentiles change a
little bit but also the thing that
happened is that there's also it's easy
for you to do that because you don't
show that so it's so easy for you to
navigate that because you're not
advertising that more than that it's
easy for me to do that because I don't
covet that
that's really important because the
other dude when he makes that money the
reason why he changes that was always in
him money just makes you more of what
you already are yeah I'm not a [__] who
values flashiness I never violated when
I was poor and I certainly don't value
it now that I got some money
but that's easy for me because I don't
care about that kind of stuff right it's
harder for them because they do want all
that stuff so once they get the money
they buy the plastic you get me yeah
that's the real problem the problem is
the money is that deep down inside you
got those desires you need the Double
D's you need the bbls right because you
need it bigger you want it flash you
want it curvy you want your mind stigma
I don't care about this right it's not
to be like maybe it's how it's race
maybe something broken in me when I was
a kid I don't know what it is I just
never cared
I actually get uncomfortable when
someone's doing too much because it's
just too much attention for me I hate
that feeling
so that's just a different set of hours
that's why I'm not worried about that I
spoke about that yeah I always say that
women actually just want an investment
now if you give her a financial
investment she's okay about the
emotional monogamy because that's a form
of investment but if there's no
Financial investment she expects more
emotional investment so you just gotta
balance it out you we want investment
whether that's Financial emotional
whatever it is now if you're not
covering us financially you better give
us all of you emotionally but if you're
covering us financially for a lot of
women they're like okay maybe you might
step out but I get to live this life
live this house have this car I know you
care about me is there anything wrong
with that no no no there's nothing wrong
with that because it's a form of care it
is a form of care it's a form of life
right like I'm saying it's a form of
investment if you want to step out and
you've got the resources for it find
that woman that wants them more as long
as she's got her financial investment
she's good don't choose the one that
needs emotional investment usually it's
the ones that have been hurt or
traumatized they need more emotional
they don't care about the finances the
women who want the emotional investment
are the ones who are traumatized or the
ones who are hurt that's not true I'll
tend to say that those people that want
the uh investment are often it's just a
coping mechanism from the motion side I
just think it's crazy that someone's
like I want loyalty and respect for my
man
and then she's like I think this person
may be traumatized or like emotionally
[__] up
because
you know
other women would judge other women no
for having that no like having having a
high value man and essentially you steps
out yeah essentially he steps out and
they're like oh my God yeah it depends
where you live
and it depends on the culture I know for
a fact that in some countries this is
already understood it is not openly
talked about and it's not overly
endorsed but it's best believe that you
have some older women put some younger
women aside and say shut the [__] up you
know what it is why are women judging
the other woman because it's easy to
judge a situation you can't access when
you can access a man that's taking you
left right and center and paying for
everything and taking you first class
then tell me what you would do in that
situation it's very easy to judge
circumstances that you can't access but
when you can access it then you can form
a more informed judgment so I think the
people that judge it can't access it so
they don't even know what that life
looks like you're thinking about can
access some people don't care it's not
that deep
like not everybody in life craves luxury
you're talking about flying first class
I've flown first class it's okay
it's I do I think it's important no
absolutely not but that's just the set
of values I was raised on and I know
that's true for a lot of other women out
there like they luxury 80 for everybody
so for some people respecting themselves
and their core values is way more
important than being able to forget the
latest Gucci Prada bag so you're saying
it's they can't access it no some people
can't access and don't want it because
all the baggage it comes with do you
think do you really think that all the
women who don't live that kind of like
high value lifestyle whatever it is it's
because they're not attractive enough or
I don't know unless they keep just
saying like the reason why these guys
saying they wouldn't spend that money is
because they don't have it I was like no
there's plenty of dudes who make a lot
of money and still live a very humble
life you hear me plenty of dudes who
make millions and will still take public
transport although still do their stuff
on a low or live life very modestly not
everybody who can afford luxury or a
luxury lifestyle lives at I would say
most of the rich people I know live
unassuming lives
the ones I've actually partially met and
like I know their net worth they live
under you would never even guess they
got money like that
so this is this idea that like oh
because you make money you must spend
money like you make money but that's
really not the case in fact I would
argue some of the stingiest and like
most penny pinching [__] I know
are rich people
and that's actually part of why they
became Rich to begin with
because they understand the value of a
dollar and they understand how to say
and so they're going to use their
connections and everything else instead
of spending money like crazy that's just
been my experience though so this is
anecdotal I have to admit that
oh [__] you just made me realize
most [__] I know that got money
like that you wouldn't know they got
money like that you know
you know you really wouldn't
and I would argue unless you'd be close
to them and around them and you don't
there's this perception that attractive
women will always go for like the riches
or whatever
but that's just because all we see is
attractive women on Instagram there's so
many attractive women who got no social
media no IG honestly that's just so
refreshing would I be meeting them in
person but they're not as easily
accessible one because they not online
like that that not everybody values that
same ideas or same things but the vast
majority of the people a lot a lot of
people that I work with
comedy and [__] like that they've been
doing this [__] for like 10 12 years and
some of them are they got it like that
and you wouldn't know you wouldn't know
there's a Oh my days there's a TV host I
know
yeah
[__] bought a scooter okay just
to go around town or whatever absolutely
but he's been he's been on these TV
whole [__] for like a good 10 years but
the reason why he bought a scooter is
actually kind of smart it's because he
values time and if you know anything
about scooters you get to break traffic
laws he actually said it him said it
himself
I don't want to show I got money like he
said that verbatim partially but I think
one of the other reasons you just move
around here the reason why I like biking
in the city is because I break every
traffic law
do you think I stopped at red lights
left right [__] I'm gone I hate you hey
Hey listen I'm a smart cyclist I don't
be here [__] up with cars okay I
still hate you why you hate me why
because I don't follow the rules I
really hate you yeah you're more you
want a motorcycle do you follow all the
rules yeah exactly exactly you don't
think I know it's just not the speeding
one uh no there's probably some other
ones you'd probably be zooming in
between cars every now and then no I
always put my flasher there's always
Place yeah yeah yeah I know you switch
your legs I know this man I know 100 if
you get on a bike what are you doing
okay let's keep going